passion we heard from Syrian President
Bashar al-assad he is not happy about
Turkey's involvement in Syria and he had
a warning for Turkey he didn't mince his
words when he was talking about turkish
President Recep Tayyip Erdogan throw in
all sorts of accusations at him saying
that he's an invader that his army is
embezzling the resources of Syria
particularly in north northern part of
the country to the point where but
President Bashar al-assad vowed
retaliation to the point where he said
that we are even ready for war if the
Turkish military decides to stay longer
in the area let's listen to what Bashar
al-assad had to say hahaha the Syrian
land is one and the theater of
operations is one from the far south to
the far north the Turk is the American
agent in this war we were fighting this
agent Turkey everywhere and whenever it
struggled to do what it wanted it left
no option but war this is obvious but I
say we will need to keep open the
opportunity for the political process in
all its forms and if it didn't produce
results then we consider them an enemy
and it will get to war there is no other
option that's frustration in the
statement of President Bashar al-assad
is because the safe zone that has been
implemented which the Turkish government
wants to be implemented along the border
with Syria is going to create huge
problems in the near future for the
Syrian government it means that the
Syrian army won't be able to take
advantage of the situation and further
expand its influence and recapture some
of the territory he lost since 2011 and
this is why Bashar al-assad has been
reiterating that if that status quo
holds his government will be left with
only one option which is to take action
to try to recapture the northeastern
part of the country including Italy
pushes the rebels last stronghold in
Syria thank you for that
Hashima Hulbert over the latest live in
shandola thank you